devant le Congrès américain Joe Biden
qui apparaît parfois fatigué c'est au
contraire montrait combatif tonique avec
l'envie de redonner de l'optimisme aux
Américains ont 19 pardon milliards
d'euros ce sont les bénéfices réalisés
par Total énergie pour l'année 2022 un
record le plus important bénéfice jamais
réalisé par la major françaises sont en
fort à noter lorsqu'il a jugé scandaleux
les gigantesques profits des compagnies
pétrolières alors que le prix de
l'essence n'a cessé d'augmenter c'est un
dessin qu'il y a un enrichissement à ce
point là d'une entreprise qui est
absolument écosystère et qui par
ailleurs travaillent avec la Russie je
le rappelle enfin vraiment rien ne va en
fait dans cette affaire au-delà des
chiffres qui peuvent choquer je l'ai dit
mais des dysfonctionnements de
l'économie mondiale qui peuvent choquer
je ne dis pas autre chose il ne faut pas
confondre ce qui relève d'un bénéfice
réalisé en France d'un bénéfice mondial
d'un groupe dont le siège social est en
France l'entreprise ne réalise
finalement que que peu de bénéfices en
France 350
gagnant d'euros l'an dernier contre près
de 20 milliards je le rappelle à
l'échelle mondiale conscient que c'est
bénéfices peuvent choquer le PDG de
Total énergie envisage désormais une
nouvelle ristourne à la pompe pour
soulager le pouvoir d'achat des Français
nous sommes tout à fait enclin à
accompagner cette annonce au total
c'est-à-dire que nous souhaitons
évidemment que une ristourne toutes les
efforts puissent être fait pour réduire
le coût du carburant à la pompe pour les
français alors que Total énergie
enregistre le meilleur bénéfice de son
histoire la grève et reconduite jusqu'à
demain soir dans la plupart des
raffineries ils sont ce matin 80% à
faire grève pour dénoncer la réforme des
retraites mais lorsqu'on les interroge
sur les profits de leur entreprise
est-ce qu'on peut vous poser une
question sur les profits de Total
énergie silence radio
est-ce qu'on peut vous poser une
question sur les bénéfices de Total
énergie ne nous dites pas de grâce
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas d'argent
dans notre pays
c'est pas le
capitité on peut taxer les dividendes
oui il y a d'autres possibilités suite à
ces annonces la façade du siège de Total
énergie a été dégradé par des militants
écologistes regardez ces images le siège
de la défense recouvert de peinture
rouge quand c'est la même chose pour le
transporteur de conteneur c'est ma CGM
qui fait 20 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices quand on a
BNP Paribas qui fait 10 milliards de
euro de bénéfice et qui en même temps
d'y vouloir supprimer 921 postes en
France sans départ contre un précise le
groupe où je cite stimuler la croissance
et la profitabilité on assiste au gavage
des uns au rationnement des autres on
assiste à une prédation de la nation il
y a et je m'en félicite parce que pour
ce qui est de ma famille de penser ça
nourrit l'idée que avec un meilleur
partage des richesses nous pourrions
collectivement vivre vieux si
vous savez pour l'instant on est
d'accord avec tout le monde dans
l'organisation syndicale la réponse non
il y a pas de faille je peux vous
assurer on s'est encore parlé hier
longuement il y a pas de faille je pense
qu'on peut mourir de nos contradictions
je le dis à l'antenne j'ai pas
l'habitude de faire la langue de bois je
pense qu'on en est là pour moi je pense
que la ligne LR ça peut pas être une
ligne ratsuk mais le gouvernement s'il
persiste mais c'est pas une question de
m'appeler simplement s'il persiste dans
la voix qui est la sienne aujourd'hui il
fait une faute démocratique qu'il paiera
très cher qu'il paiera très cher ça
s'appelle pas une menace ça s'appelle un
avertissement collectif quel besoin on
sait français de dire d'avoir une droite
qui dirait non il y a pas besoin de
veiller à l'argent public on peut
toujours plus dépenser il y a pas besoin
de ça on a Mélenchon on a Le Pen l'image
que donne en particulier et les filles
et absolument effrayante pourquoi
je veux dire transformer l'Assemblée
nationale en camp de gitan et c'est pas
les Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer c'est à
dire c'est record du plus grand manège
de glace du monde est tombée et c'est un
finlandais qu'on le doit son nom Yann un
capyletto il en fallait pas plus pour
leur faire dire ceci avec du racisme en
plus la honte ça c'est pour Manuel
Bompard et puis son collègue elle est
fille Alexis Corbière on remet une
petite couche en parlant de mes prix
racistes qui doit être condamné
unanimement cette violence verbale
dit-il doit cesser disque mesure 516
mètres de diamètre et 42 cm d'épaisseur
l'ensemble tourne sur lui-même grâce à
des moteurs